d'autres invités de ce soir beaucoup ce
qu'il fait d'ailleurs toutes les
grands-mères l'aiment bien sylvie joly
muriel robin jacqueline maillan voici
l'enfant prodige du nouveau rire pierre
palmade
[Musique]
excusez moi mais vous ne seriez pas
pierre palmade sarrazin ça c'est drôle
ça fait deux fois qu'on me dit
aujourd'hui c'est c'est la coiffure je
crois qu'il fait ça le brushing qui
ressemble énormément influé elle vient
pas de là vous auriez aimé ressembler à
qui quand il était petit à fantômas
mais on est étonnant pourquoi j'ai envie
de demander parce que
je trouvais qu'il sans déguisement était
réussi à vraiment comme si j'étais petit
alors au fond est ce que vous vous aimez
merci à vous lui est ce que vous vous
aimez au fond ouais mais non de surface
je veux bien
oui oui oui oui oui je préfère qu'on me
le dise quoi on vous aime
merci une autre question on dans les
questions tant pis je me lance vous
changeriez quoi en rouge si vous aviez
une baguette magique
j'ai une baguette magique déjà je me
ferais une tronche de fait pour l'heure
- cours d'accor et non me changerait non
trop longtemps moi je voulais tout
change et puis maintenant je me dis que
mère je veux dire c'est rare d'être
tient un grattage l'accord est ce que ça
vous plaît quand vous reconnaissent dans
la rue
j'aime bien j'aime bien pas le dimanche
quand j'ai fait la fête le samedi soir
avec dimanche je sens pour acheter mon
pain puis le brushing comme ça qu'on me
demande si c'est bien gentil fait le
siège là j'ai envie de dire non
le reste du temps et ça me plaît bien
alexis je dirais pas que j'ai un début
d'érection mais c'est vrai que je dit
moi vous avez été obligé de coucher pour
réussir
ouais avec muriel robin ah oui quand
même est-ce que vous pensez que vous
méritez ce qui vous arrive vous croyez
que ça va durer je suis un chanteur qui
a fait un tube quoi je crois que
l'humour c'est plus c'est ce un coup
d'oeil sur la vie qu'on a et puis qu'on
garde tout en quoi tout aussi sa maman
ne regrettez vous pas déjà d'avoir
accepté d'être invité dans cette
émission
non je vais la faire ce soir merci bien
fade
au caire on va carrément la jouer télé
tu veux bien vous connaît la télé en
direct j'ai le trac juin date moi aussi
pour le moment tu en tournée oui là je
tourne je tourne nourish chantourner tué
au vagin quoi poitiers aquatour 27 à
limoges 36 arabe tu as dit le rire c'est
jackpot s'est fait du blé c'est pas moi
qui ai dit ça ainsi cette fois kobe ça
bon je vais le défendre
j'étais première étonnée moi quand on
m'a dit ah oui en plus on est pays
vraiment ce que ça génial mais tant
mieux tant mettant dès jeudi
singer vous avez combien il ya de
l'argent bigard oui plus que moi alors
qu'il est beaucoup moins connu c'est
mieux que c'était moi tu m'as dit
j'espère que c'est toi qui l'a dit vous
aussi
le théâtre c'est le stade supérieur du
one man show je parle pour moi quoi j'ai
envie de faire du théâtre peuvent même
chose parce qu'ils matin commence je
commence à me sentir seul j'ai envie
d'avoir un regard en face de moi comme
j'ai envie de ça que je vais répondre
ouais c'est bien le fond dur puisqu'on
avait dit que comme attaché de presse
c'est vrai après j'ai vraiment envie la
transition c'est que la pièce de jacques
puisque j'ai écrites pour jacqueline
maillan ouais ça cette transition je
passe par l'auteur et puis après j'ai
envie de rêve de jouer avec ses copains
sur cette fois c'est quoi cette place ça
s'appelle comment
pièce montée et c'est une pièce de
théâtre pour une femme seule pendant une
heure et demie donc tu écris un one man
show pour une femme de théâtre
voilà ce que c'est pas des sketches tu
l'a connue comment jacques est le
meilleur que j'aurais dit elle m'en
parlait d'elle quand je vais à paris
finalement dit que je l'adorais qu'un
jour elle a dû le savoir être qui elle
m'a appelé en me demandant si je vous
aime bien rencontrons nous c'est une
technique ça oui bah oui je sais pas
comment faire c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut dire aux jeunes qui débutent
oui moi non le meilleur conseil qu'il
faut redonner c'est pas le faire ce
métier comme ça si le fort malgré malgré
ce qu'on sait c'est que ils en ont
vraiment besoin c'est un métier qu'on
fait pas par envie je crois que sa
musique aussi par besoin que ça suffit
pas ou alors faut s'appeler jean pierre
françois a beaucoup de chance peut-être
que j'adore il s'appelle le colonel oui
tous les matins à 6 heures il ya ya ya
un type il faut absolument trouver qui
c'est qui joue de la trompette ou du
saxophone je sais pas ce que c'est comme
instrument mais ça réveille tout le
monde en plus il joue pratiquement
toujours la même chose c'est irritant
il faut faire quelque chose tu as fait
la remets toi toi c'est un enchaînement
tout ça de suite ça fait leur maître non
j'ai eu du bol j'ai commencé j'ai fait
de la télévente chars de l'armée quand
je suis arrivé aux trois jours je leur
ai dit moi je suis capable de le faire
mais mais
si je m'arrête maintenant pendant un an
ça commence à marcher que deux j'avais
pour le faire aujourd'hui d'accord et
puis je parte il manquait à paris ils
m'ont dit on vous laisse partir libre je
gagnais et mais en échange si vous tapez
d'accueil à cannes public vous tapez pas
trop sur l'armée un deal pour évoquer
ton adolescence mais mon enfance et j'ai
de faire une petite interview première
fois bon tu es prêt oui première boum
première boum avec ça je me rappelle de
tout les boomers toujours pareil m'a
invité pour faire rire
la première partie de soirée puis dit
que les slows arriver on me demande est
restée près du buffet j'ai dernièrement
c'est aussi première idole première
idole au boeuf commence à se savoir
jeudi que j'aime vraiment beaucoup
claude françois
tu vois les toutes ses chansons par
coeur a pas mal pas mal pas mal je suis
pas fétichiste ont marre je dis ça j'ai
acheté un costume du bio aux enchères
est ce que tu sais qui a écrit les
lundis au soleil
ouais c'est qu'il y ait un copain
s'appelle patrick g bravo à la plénière
premiers pleurs premier flirt c'est dans
un autocar d'un fond avec la plus belle
en direction de l'italie
j'étais j'ai dû tout dernier dans ma
classe d'habitude chauffeur il est à
l'avant les années de ma classe sortir
avec une fille ouais je serais bien
passé quand même bien je pensais qu'on
veut pas inspiré du film montrent s'il
fut première cuite
la dernière salle entière alors la
première je sus votre en boutre au lycée
ouais il s'en suivait pas
particulièrement non non non non je te
bourrer du premier vrai amour premier
vrai amour doit être à muriel robin je
vous que je suis ne m'entendais bien
d'un modèle première expérience sexuelle
ben oui on m'a dit moi il fallait
absolument j'ai merde j'avais 19 ans
faut absolument que je suis pas seul un
lac à l'acte et je me suis renseigné sur
la fille la plus facile du lycée qui est
tout est accepté
c'est passé comme une lettre à la poste
1er juin 1er juin c'était selon temps à
la police est bon il n'ya pas longtemps
au nom au collège au collège du collège
françois dumas j'étais vraiment on était
fous qu'on veut c'est n'importe quoi on
fumait du café du thé
ça fait sérieux son premier procès j'en
ai pas encore eu non il ya non non je
veux en faire un point sur un cône a
rappelé wermus la liste qu'elle quitte à
des rats reporter des salons de thé
kennedys mais qu'il l'avait dit je vous
le rappelle
rappelons le cap allemagne et autre
qu'un pâle imitateur de sylvie joly donc
ça m'avait énervé quoi way qui le disent
qu'ils ne dévoilent premier vide premier
bid ce soir
il
il est là sur le plateau ils vous
regardent vous avez une question à lui
poser
eux non sont proches tous ici s'il fait
prochain qu'on dira un olympia quelque
chose un prochain spectacle
alors oui pierre il vient de faire un
olympia et non attends c'est pas déroger
des récents jeux atteint forcément suivi
toute sa carrière s'est fait la malle
paix trouvé notre question la suisse est
bonne chance
je prends pas des mongoliens pierre je
pense que je trouve alors soit pas celle
non plus trouvé une question
intelligente j'ai pas qui sera déposé je
suis désolé pour la peta ok alors alors
allez c'est pas de moi j'ai rien à lui
dire vu que ma soeur c'est une [ __ ] a
rien à lui dire pourquoi ya pas plus
originales
ils font sans beaucoup trop
l'influencent de jolis attendait il me
répond non c'est pas une [ __ ]
jedermann questions à se poser
ça peut pas te plaire toujours pierre
une question mais je croyais la [ __ ]
va sortir du champ pierre monsieur ben
voila merci bon j'ai pas je vois pas ce
que pourrait lui poser comme question
elle étonne pas et me dit je crois qu
est-ce qui fait cesser dans le mot
sexuelle il est en larmes vous avez
gagné bravo
ok merci mais ça détend laruns je sais
pas je savais pas que pourrait poser
c'est qu'ils trouvent ces conneries hier
en écoutant des blaireaux comme vous une
idée bien jouer garçon je me demande où
jesi seul trou attendait parce qu'il me
parle dans le casque la non pierre c'est
pas une vieille [ __ ] madame te
connais pas tout le monde n'est pas
obligé que non parce que vous le
connaissez pas alors moi je suis non
soit pas aux dieux pierre je veux dire
moi je te connais pas c'est tout c'est
un corps est ce que vous dites là que je
ne connais pas la personne en question
c'est pourquoi je vois bien valable a
mal pris c'est pas très correct de tape
alors madame possède une question là je
pense pas de questions les gens qui sont
incorrectes je ne permets pas un soi
disant monsieur chapron comment la qui
se permettent de dire qu'à 81 108 une
[ __ ] c'est honteux
d'accord avec vous il me dit vous dire
qu'il n'a pas dit [ __ ] non non
attendez ce que je dis il a dit il n'a
pas dit [ __ ] il a dit vieille péta
c'est pas mieux
c'est plus profond alors c'est pas le
mode qui a dit oh là là c'est pas grave
c'est pas moi c'est pas le match à dix
connards s'est-il sa palme a way
[Applaudissements]
et à la moindre des choses c'était
presque jusqu'aux tête et un petit peu
loin là est ce que tu es prêt pour
l'interview coq à l'âne ah oui oui oui
tu es prêt oui tu as déjà pensé au
suicide
je dois essayer et à la baisse avait été
essayé comment non je veux comme ça une
déprime j'avais les trois rivières par
lagaf
3 ridicule 3 ridicule
temesta et juste après j'ai appelé un
copain en disant je crois que j'ai fait
une connerie j'ai dormi deux jours pour
une fois que tu veux mais tu dirais quoi
de négatif sur toi tu vraiment être qu'à
ses proches
moi je trouve que je me lâche pas c'est
mes amis je trouve que je m'occupe
tellement de séduire quoi quand c'est à
qui j'ai tendance à négliger quoi il
faudrait pas je m'en rends compte pas ce
que je fais bien les gars soit en tout
cas ça me renvoie une mauvaise image de
moi quand as tu pleurais pour la
dernière fois
quand on m'a dit que j'allais sur
l'émission non non quand je pleurais pas
dernière fois ça va être n'importe quoi
une série télé mad et qu'il ya un truc
n'importe quoi qui s'est écrasé je sais
qu'en ce bar est tu pleures des fois
quand ils se retrouvent mais je suis
obligé maintenant simon producteur celle
où va donc j'ai oublié de charmants et
quant à signer avec nous à quoi
reconnait tue la passion naissante
quand je joue plus de corps j'oublie
tout le reste est là là je me casse les
dents pendant talent et la passion qui
ne fait pas un patient qui s'éteint
quand ça m'énerve physiquement quand il
ya quelqu'un m'énerve c'est si c'est
ouais tu appuies photo kim pas vraiment
arrête syrie est-ce que tu est attiré
par les pratiques déviantes style
sadomasochisme non non non je trouve que
je suis mythomane de par mes romans je
m'empresse gd plein de défauts mais je
pas facile du tout quoi bien faire
l'amour dans un lit la nuit lumières
éteintes sans être attaché
j'ai pas de côté j'ai cas la personne en
tout cas
bah écoute on va voir si je lis ce que
j'aime bien c'est parfait ce qu'ils ont
à me dire et moi toi tu sais ce qui
t'attend la paluche excités se retrouver
tous les deux dans un coin sombre merde
professional oui tu es prêt oui tu me
suis dit qu'avec ces l'interview
confession
et
[Musique]
quels sont tes tabou se dit je ne
rigolerai jamais avec la religion et le
sida 1
c'est à dire que je ne révèlerai jamais
parce que ça me fait pas rire mais c'est
pas des tabous je crois que j'ai aucun
tabou ya rien que j'ai cédé aux cantons
de rien éviter mais il ya des choses qui
ne font pas rire comme la le sida ça
fait parler parce que parce que ça ne
fait pas et la religion je vois pas
comment je crois en rire quoi je parle
j'ai plutôt contraint je suis vraiment
une il y soit c'est à dire que c'est un
pas que je crois qu'il n'existe pas
c'est que je crois que s'il est là je
vois pas sa place en tout cas je parle
j'en passe qui à quoi ils serviront
jamais été effleurée par l'idée de
l'existence de dieu non ça m'aide pas de
savoir qu'il ya quelque chose après
quelqu'un qui m'attend après donc
quelqu'un qui est plus fort que j'ai
besoin de savoir ça et c'est l'homme le
plus fort qu'est-ce que tu le regrette
d'abord c'est ça hein non parce que non
parce que du coup je suis mon propre
dieu et j'ai pas se donne une force ça
me donne un caractère de vainqueur chose
quand on perd et marque le pas été
tentés de trac rocher à l'idée de
l'existence de dieu non non je commence
cette roche conceptrice que maintenant
il manque maintenant sur coup j'ai parme
à réaliser quoi sur coup c'était c'était
quelqu'un j'étais triste pour l'homme et
l'agrandir la l'autorité garder cet
égard si le terme peut énormément peur
et et quand elle n'a plus été là quelque
part
ça m'a aidé moi je me suis dit que il y
aurait plus jamais personne qui n'aurait
pas froid puisque malheureusement sept
personnes était plus là mais bon et
c'est maintenant par contre que je me
mets à pleurer dans un feu rouge parce
que je dis merde [ __ ] s'il était là
pour voir ce qu'il m'arrive très fier
dites-moi pierre j'ai lu dans la presse
que vous étiez pas bien si tu es malade
mais j'ai lu aussi
ouais j'ai lu aussi je ne savais pas et
est alors eh oui les médecins sont trois
ans mais rld est il ya aussi dit on veut
rien donc je vais je je vais voir à mesa
avec leurs conneries tu vois je leur ai
dit j'en dis suis malade
il dit qu'ils avaient jugé pas mais je
les lui alors faut absolument trouver
leurs marques et pierre palmade à un
hors-jeu les gens meurent des personnes
qui les lie à marquer gros soucis de
santé
alors j'ai fait les analyses donc là une
fortune et c'est le pire c'est que ça
s'est su et du coup ils ont marqué après
grosses inquiétudes autour de bien pâles
mal puisqu'on le voit partout dans les
hôpitaux
on s'en sort plus mais faut lire les
journaux on apprend plein de choses on
apprend plein de choses à gérer appris
que j'avais acheté une rolls par les
journaux la nage et frais mais j'essaie
le journal sur l'avant de ma poule o et
je peux dire que ça le faisait ça on va
dire et pour les histoires d'amour des
fois c'est bien des fois non l'année
dernière c'était bien ce que j'étais cas
et des filles superbes et cette année il
n'est tombé pas revu une fois sur une
photo bien ces tests avec un mec donc je
te protéger une fois j'avais lu
formidable acteur il sait tout faire
les français l'aiment vers là j'étais
vraiment content pour daniel auteuil
voilà inutile de vous dire que des
experts du nouveau spectacle de pierre
donc on va en parler dans un instant qui
sera à partir du 17 décembre au palais
des congrès salle bordeaux puisque donc
comme on disait tout à l'heure voilà
vous allez au palais des congrès parce
que la salle s'appelle bordeaux bien sûr
ses co écrit avec un tas de gens qui ont
énormément de talent et à michel blanc
et jean loup dabadie
les gérard darmon ya ramzy dehbia d'eric
et ramzy
muriel robin françois bar live voilà
alors les quelques sketches bon on va
pas les raconter parce qu est ce que ça
sera que vous raconte pas la télé ça va
se voir enfin et les choix impossible en
saas et j'étais particulièrement
sensible parce que j'ai la rue c'était
des questions cons on demandait aux gens
s'ils préféraient hitler ou staline leur
père ou leur mère
alors là bon ça commence avec les
lentilles et les lunettes très simple
voilà effet après c'est quelqu'un qui se
posent des questions pas très qui pour
lui sont vitales comme s'il me faire
avoir des dents bois ou une jambe en
mousse mais pour lui cela s'est très
vite aller
et plus encore par areva règlent envoie
bouler et puis ça l'énervé est-ce que tu
préfère avoir une tiare linda vous
préfériez avoir une tête de veau ou un
bras de 9 m visé parce que la tête de
veau bon d'accord vous gardez votre voix
est ce que ma voix jour vous vous dites
mon jour normalement raté quand même pas
dire bonjour fait plusieurs fois le tour
est très grand a posé la question à
michel noir parce que lui une mesure
quand même pratiquement neuf mètres donc
peut-être qu'avec un bad est ce que il
ya aussi une truc linda je vous la jouer
si poser des questions quand je suis
ravi mais j'ai fait c est ce que vous
préférez répéter chaque fois que vous
essayez où est suivi par 40 canard par
exemple ces avis bien sûr ces avis oui
c'est pas d'la 40 canard c'est la vie
tout et partout où vous allez vous les
40 canard qui vous suit l'iran canard 40
canard carenco nar alors maintenant on
va faire un ordi view ah oui un ordi
view alors ccaf alors pas bougé pendant
le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien vous faites bien ça ça c'est
regarder devant lui c'est un truc vous
fait vachement bien alors c'est très
simple vous pensez à quoi là par exemple
comment vont trouver physiquement j'ai
même pas plutôt la sava ouais c'est vrai
mais pas l'antenne pas l'antenne qu est
la dernière chose que vous faites avant
de vous coucher
je ferai un lexomil c'est pas très
original mais quoi je vais pas vous dire
que ça fait quoi les gens les apprécient
ça fait quoi un lexomil
ça calme ça ça et plusieurs en pêche de
se réveiller au milieu de la nuit
maintenant quand vous sortez pas mal bon
sens - ben ouais mais là maugendre oui
donc agir j'ai pas arrêté de dormir
définitivement gorge et le matin que
vous voyez dans la glace nous dit quoi
par exemple la première chose que vous
dites quand vous voyez comme ça que je
rendormir à bien une heure ou deux quand
vous étiez petit bouddha semble acquis
un peu à claude françois
je sais pas je n'ai pas trop ma tronche
il y en a qui on dirait on comprend non
je vous la jouer à être quelqu'un de
jouer quelqu'un d'autre voilà c'est
peut-être ça la maturité c'est que plus
ça va moi j'en vis de quelqu'un d'autre
vous accepter ça y est voilà je commence
à un an toute la france vous acceptiez
commencer par en accepter vous
finalement bal avec d'abord les autres
vous accès voilà tu m'emmerdes en
psychanalyse a oui ou par des balles
alors quelle est la phrase que vous ne
supportez pas d'entendre
je suis bien avec toi parce que j'en ai
marre des mecs bot entendus ça quand
j'étais adolescent ça m'avait choqué et
puis non qu'est ce que je n'aime pas
entendre si bien et toi parce que j'aime
les mecs qui me font rire mais oui mais
c'est pas incompatible j'ai l'impression
que quand on fait un compliment c'est
pour dire que non je te vois est ce que
je suis je peux entendre
non pour l'instant ça va aller on ne dit
rien de désagréable ce qui vous énerve
le plus en vous non non je suis
peut-être un peu des jeux tel un peu
désinvolte avec avait des gens qui
m'aiment bien et des fois comme je
trouve que c'est acquis je vais plutôt à
la conquête des gens qui m'aiment pas
encore voilà je vous êtes déjà cm du
mans le maître du monde c'est dieu lui
un sentiment de puissance absolue
ça fait ça quand on est sur scène ouais
quand on le cherchait nous quand on fait
très très bien l'amour ça fait un peu ça
elle souhaite déjà senti une sous merde
sur cinq ans dans une semaine vous avez
un besoin de vous dire si oui je dirai
pas quand ou avec qui d'accord comment
aimeriez-vous mourir assez rapidement
j'aimerais bien qu'on commence à signer
pendant mon sommeil parce que assassiné
sa fille avec un examine en plus sentir
mais on va s'y est alors si c'était à
refaire votre vie qu'est-ce que vous ne
feriez pas du tout pareil
je crois qu'un foutu comme je suis je
referais tout partout les mêmes quand
même si vous savez ouais ouais j'irai
dans les mêmes murs presque aller dans
un mur on a une bosse pendant quelques
temps et puis après ça passe moins
s'endurcit vous pensez que non alors
marque donc la cma ailier m'a choqué je
crois pas aux claques qui vous aide dans
la vie ouais non parce qu'au bout d'un
moment on est un peu sonnés après on
recommence son oeuf cet incorrigible
ouais ouais bon allumer la lumière merci
dans l'avion ça va ça va ça s'est bien
passé avant ouais ben ça va très très
bien bien sûr ça très bien vous
connaissez donc josé bové laurie bbc
loris tu peut ce que dany boon jean
michel alors nous le présente plus et
zabou j'ai croisé là le film ne le film
de zabou marche très très bien se
souvenir des belles choses marchent très
bien très très bon démarrage
on est ravi parce que ça va quand même
une vingtaine d'années qu'elle se
prépare d'empiler les bons qu'on voit
c'est un heureusement que ça marche pas
du résumé des émissions non plus ils
avaient qu'à être là mais il arrive du
théâtre parlé des tarifs du terrain
c'est pour ceux qui pensent que
l'émission est en direct
il arrive du théâtre merci pour
l'enchaînement donc au théâtre ils se
sont aimés de tir et embrasse à sur la
bouche je l'aï dit mais bon c'est pas je
le dirai à michelle
j'allais à bord sept michèle laroque
donc la pièce effectivement été écrite
par muriel robin et pierre palmade et
les jouets par pierre palmade et la
merveilleuse michel l'arbre aux gros
gros succès un ouais ça ça va les gens
viennent ils allaient ils ont humé de la
fin de la première expérience s'est
parfaitement suivi c'est pas d'en faire
bien avec aqua c'est rare de tadrart un
couple qui marche et frédéric beigbeder
disait dans vsd que c'était en france le
seul truc était de qualité seinfeld
voilà donc ça s'est très bien passé
encerclés sur la ville a adoré sa maman
mais c'est vrai voilà et puis après il
ya un petit peu de tourner non ouais
voilà les voies détournées pile zénith
alors faisait déjouer ça au zénith et
indignés dans une configuration humaine
on va faire avant d'aller enfin mille
personnes très très près d'alors pierre
et jean michel vous avez pas mal de
choses en commun finalement tous les
deux en dehors du village déjà oui oui
ça arrange bien le dire vous avez
d'abord alors le père absent
les sens comme un tir que vous bon là
dit votre père est parti aux états unis
xavier cinq ans pierre s'est
malheureusement encore plus triste
artillerie il est parti et on y
reviendra pas céder d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire bonjour à mon père si
nous regarde
ouais parce que tv5 effectivement il ya
80 pays qui regardent cette émission et
donc je le salue bon voilà à tout hasard
à tout hasard c'est peut-être qu'il va
vous appeler et donc il faudrait que
cela passe au paradis mais c'est déjà
une chose en commun g7 s'étaient absence
de père vous effectivement il décider
comment oui bon ça lui fait tant parler
mais ça se sent sans compter entre les
deux nos mères plus tôt enfin justement
oui tous les deux élevés par vos mères
pas malheureusement est donc très proche
tous les deux de vos mères aussi
finalement et réciproquement sont très
proches de nous alors beaucoup de points
communs donc le père absent élevés par
des mères est aussi vous avez choisi
tous les deux des femmes femmes vous
charlotte vous véronique sanson ça aussi
c'est quelque chose qui vous rapproche
vous ai déjà parlé encore parler non
plus on a beaucoup bossé cependant
l'annoncé une éminence et une âme titre
et 9,1 mais il ya des choses qu'on a pas
besoin de se dire en fait finalement si
c'est vous qui nous le dit et on va se
parler certainement après mr
ensemble après projets seront absents
qui ont travaillé ça me rappelle un peu
comme quand j'ai rencontré mur elle
revint on s'est rencontrés un soir on
sait pas parler on savait qu'on se
rassembler et lendemain on a écrit
ensemble et jean-michel je lui ai dit un
soir j'ai vu un blaireau en boîte une
des rares fois où j'allais en boîte de
nuit où il y était il ya un type qui a
dit à la femme qui est à côté de moi toi
je te slash de l'homme et je vais dire à
jean-michel qui dit lui prend tout
jean-michel si vous faites tomber une
fourchette de tarifs et refait le faire
bien sûr il me dit ça c'est pas si la
troisième fille écoute si je te fais une
musique est ce que tu me fais les
paroles trois ans plus tard et me dit
écoute j'ai la musique ou l'oeuf écoutez
je découvre chercher les paroles
j'arrive une fois un coup pour rien ce
que j'étais arrivé j'avais un peu trop
bu il a enregistré un bond de faire
parce que tu as beaucoup dormi mais
voilà mais pas tant ce n'était pas la
bonne elle à la première fois était pas
la bonne foi et pendant qu'on pensait de
mireille dumas j'aime dit qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui serait originales de films
et je dis bah voila je les écoute je
veux faire les paroles pour demain je
fais les paroles si l'agent michel banco
et on a filmé tout d'un coup ça fait
dans l'urgence comme beaucoup de choses
que je fais
[Musique]
ça marche et ça c'est pas en tout cas c
'est c'est une récréation cesse
d'annoncer ça si c'est par un coup c'est
une récréation
alors on se prend pas au sérieux assez
pour le faire et mais je pense tout ça
parce que c'est un truc comique non plus
récents un truc drôle mais je peux pas
marcher sur les plates-bandes de lagaf
cent des revenus sans ironie que je
compte non mais je parie daou
voilà quoi je suis vachement cher les
lionnes ses chansons paru si ça marche
on veut dire on dit on va faire les 24
heures du mec en question ça qu'il s'est
pris des râteaux toute la soirée
il rentre chez lui oui c'est assez
spécial c'est le deuxième qui djabaret
dans le cancer
il passe la nuit à annecy de se suicider
mais il veut pas anormal donc il essaie
différentes formes de suicide mais sans
douleur mais ça marche pas non plus etc
c'est bien jean michel je vais vous
faire à tous les deux une interview nul
mais avant de passer l'intérêt nul je
voudrais que vous disiez un mot de votre
combat pour les homosexuels égyptien
puisque vous avez lancé une une pétition
ouais raconter ce qui se passe en deux
mots et disait sur le manche oui c'est
pas de la fiction ces pics qui élit à la
réalité malheureusement très brièvement
il ya tout le monde je pense a dû voir
ça à la télévision il y à un certain
nombre de jeunes égyptiens qui ont été
victimes d'une rafle en mai dernier au
caire devant une boîte s'appelle de
queen boat qui s'apparente plus
d'ailleurs que je connais bien parce que
je suis allé souvent au caire qui
s'apparente plus au jardin
d'acclimatation plutôt qu'aux queen de
paris qu'on connaît et c'est ces jeunes
gens se sont fait donc prendre par la
police et le 14 novembre dernier en 2001
14 novembre 2001 ils ont été 23 d'entre
eux ont été condamnés à des peines
allant jusqu'à cinq ans de prison sans
possibilité d'appel pour certains
avec des peines de travaux forcés en
l'absence de leurs avocats et leurs
familles pour soupçon d'homosexualité et
donc effectivement il ya un certain
nombre d'associations gaies et pas
seulement d'ailleurs qui font un travail
formidable à travers le monde pour
essayer de faire d'eux de faire sortir
ces gens et j'ai eu et j'ai eu le
réflexe en voyant était en voyant ces
types cagoulés partant dans leurs
prisons sur des sur des camions plateaux
et des grillages de cabanas lapin est
con qui disparaissent donc pendant
pendant cinq ans de faire quelque chose
en fonction du fait que effectivement
moi j'suis pas pétitionnaires mais c'est
un pays que je connais bien que j'aime
bien
j'ai eu beaucoup de d'appel de
d'artistes d'intellectuels copains en
egypte qui m'ont dit on ne peut pas
faire grand chose mais il faut
absolument que vous vous essayez de
faire quelque chose de l'extérieur
d'egypte parce que nous vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de nous et nos familles on
risque beaucoup beaucoup
et au fond c'est ce pays qui est
finalement notre le berceau de notre
civilisation le berceau notre mémoire
puisqu'il faut dire satellite a été un
pays très tolérant l'époque de landry
avant la nationalisation alexandrie
c'est une ville cosmopolite tollé assure
youssef chez nous à l'habitation d'un
seul coup 7,7 cette mesure qui est
plutôt moyenâgeuse qui complètement
obscur en piste au fond
fait qu'on ne peut pas nous laisser un
pays qu'on aime se refermer sur lui-même
surtout en ce moment avec ce qui se
passe dans cette région et que
effectivement j'ai donc pris
l'initiative de faire une pétition sous
la forme d'une lettre ouverte au
président moubarak pour lui demander une
chose simple parce qu'il ya tellement de
gens qui souffrent dans cette région du
monde sans qu'on puisse faire grand
chose là c'est très facile il suffit
qu'ils signent au bas d'un papier et qui
trouve le mec qui a la clé et qui loue
la porte et ya 23 pts qui peuvent se
tient demain matin je pense que cette je
pense que pour que cette décision ait
lieu lundi en egypte ils ont besoin que
la communauté internationale se réveille
c'est ce que vous faites tous les jours
avec voit toutes les semaines avec
michaël blanc on essaie le problème de
genre de choses c'est qu'on est tous
scandalisés quand les choses se font et
puis finalement on oublie iphone ou mika
ce qu'on a nos vies on a tant de choses
et ce qui est difficile c'est de
continuer et moi j'ai décidé de
continuer toute façon quoi qu'il arrive
si ça marche pas je dirais ok revoir
moubarak et une pelle dans un deuxième
temps c'est à dessein d'hippocrate il
aura libéré les mails voilà attention
interview nul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant le génial alors allons-y pierre
palmade ça tombe sur vous vous devez
partir dans un vaisseau spatial pendant
trois ans est-ce que vous préféré partir
avec elizabeth teissier madame de
fontenay ou nadine de rothschild les
habitations est déjà dans les étoiles
donc je la trouvais que je l'amène qui
d'autre madame de fontenay et ses miss
france où nadine de rothschild je pense
elle que je connais pas je prendre
nadine nadine raguet
alors jean michel jarre si vous aviez le
choix vous préféreriez faire l'amour
avec une fille très laide ou avec un mec
très beau un qe2 peut-être ou et
peut-être oui ptête ouais enfin il faut
voir c'est difficile à sa défense ça
dépend de la laideur et de la beauté
c'est ce qu'on a fait est très subjectif
la laideur à la fiche du match elle est
vraiment moche est quand même très
dirigé ta réponse à combien vous êtes du
sport cette question remercie
maintenant c'est à vous maintenant le
mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore
ou oui oui l'originalité dire jusqu'au
mariage
j'irai à dire le mot le plus qu en amour
merci le plus con je vais te dire c'est
quelqu'un mais je dis c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a reconnu pendant les rapports
aller à qui j'étais rentré comme j'ai la
personne était un peu embrumé moi aussi
et c'est pendant les rapports la
personne a ouvert les yeux fait au pire
veulent me
[Applaudissements]
ça m'a un petit peu déstabilisé jean
michel est ce que vous savez vous lécher
la langue
[Rires]
non on va essayer à partir d'aujourd'hui
non mais c'est un bon tous les lots
réussite vous lécher la langue
ah mais si si si on peut en perdre
nation qu'on peut pas mais je sais je
sais or faisait on
il faut s'aider du palais ouais non pas
le vous lécher la moustache josé
laissait alors qu'en fait c'est pas dur
si difficile j'avais dénoncé la langue
c'est un peu con mais c'est pas nous
c'est ça le service public bien
attention talent made nous sommes seuls
qui tous les deux vous et moi d'accord
bloqué l'hiver dans un chalet il fait
très froid il ya trois mètres de neige
on a rien à bouffer je meurs de froid
vous mourrez de faim
vous me manger vous commencez par quoi
le mandat josé mazères est de dire
qu'est ce qu'une meilleure dans les
stades meilleur dans l'art fiscaux
filgoal on a une bonne tranche un beau
cuissots un mot qui sonne dollar 10 ans
et wauja le bas des oreilles c'est pas
mal d'eau douce à pour commencer
j'attendais à celle là c'est là les durs
jean michel vous préféreriez être
réincarné en slip de françois hollande
je sais que françois bayrou ou de
nicolas sarkozy ça c'est très très dur
ce qui est bien quel est le plus propre
at on alors choisir dans quel ce qu'ils
voulaient être incarné ce que vous savez
que vous serez réincarné en slip jeu
suicide ah ouais je suis si je me
suicide avant avant d'incarner
apparemment quand on se suicide en ai
pas regardé dans l'oreille vous pierre
palmade vous préféreriez être incarnée
en slip de françois hollande de françois
bayroux ou de nicolas sarkozy alors
comment comment on peut savoir qu'elle
prend preuve nicolas sarkozy c'est ce
que je connais donc françois bayrou le
matin à passe sans slip palmade
[Applaudissements]
bien alors jean michel jarre ça tombe
sur vous vous préféreriez mourir comme
otis redding dans un crash d'avion
john lennon un shot à bout portant
janis joplin une ode in over dose ou
comme john bonham le batteur de led zep
qui est mort étouffé dans son vomi
ça c'est pas une question nul sauf le
dernier cas ouais je dirais john lennon
john lennon mois que ce soit rapide à
bout portant
ouais ouais et vous voyagez pas je
voudrais pas donner des idées aux gens
mais assassiné je jouais à crash d'avion
je supporterai pas très bas une ode et
c'est pas terrible si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex shop vous seriez quoi
je parle à la réponse que vous dites là
la marque et c'est tout ben vous un truc
flatteur l'ong est flatteur moi je dis
virilement facteurs d'accord il apparaît
jean michel vous seriez quoi vous étiez
en vente dans un sex-shop un mode
d'emploi du temps c'est ça tombe sur
vous vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un oeil supplémentaires
un doigt supplémentaire ou alors quoi un
sexe oui évidemment un supplémentaire de
sexe mariées 2 bon c'est pas mal bah oui
un oeil à un oeil c'est ça fait un peu
mon jeu tandis qu'un chèque
supplémentaire venant des auditoires et
jean-michel un sexe d'homme en plus ou
un sexe de femme avons une bonne
question à l'eau froide
ça serait pas mal de temps sec c'est
normal et 2 way les deux et vous moi
j'ai déjà les deux
voici le pied en chine enfin si pierre
balle mal
s'enquiert soir comment ça va très très
bien on est ce qu'on est bien dans ce
carré viiip là bas c'est quand j'étais
tout seul c'était pas mal mais c'est que
la belgique est arrivé oui je sais je
préfère revenir au plateau comme
frédéric vous avez passé vos vacances
j'ai un petit village dans le var
pas loin de sainte maxime c'est ça alors
dites moi vous n'avez pas complètement
perdu votre temps à saint tropez où je
vais fait une fête pour les soldats du
feu n'ont oui c'est ni de régime qui
s'est dit parce que là on était en plein
dans le var ont mis les incendies et 10
ont fait rien pour les pompiers
finalement à part les plaindre et le 18
août et on va essayer de faire en sorte
que tous les ans
le 18 août ça soit un bal pour les
pompiers ça va s'appeler le 18 c'est les
pompiers est notée parce que oui
alors effet nous ça aurait été pour les
enseignements mais en fait le 18 donc
c'est pour les pompiers par un des
pompiers régine la marraine
comment ça va se passer non non on a
juste lancé cette idée et puis voilà on
beaucoup de mères en france sont
d'accord pour que leurs villages et
leurs villes
le diaboliser un c'est les pompiers
n'ont pas toutes oeuvres caritatives
souhaite une bonne idée jeudi les médias
quand même c'est pas parce que c'est pas
votre idée mais n'ont plus évolué ces
médecins sans frontières mais enfin
c'est vrai que c'est une bonne idée
la soirée des pompiers a été gâchée
quand même par une altercation de régine
non avec le dj louie jim bruit parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont confondu une
soirée tropézienne avec une soirée à
saint tropez
c'est quoi la différence la différence
c'est que c'est une soirée populaire et
c'était pas une soirée pour pour faire
monter
trois pistes sur la table trois russes
et faire dégommer des bouteilles de
champagne c'était vraiment un bal
populaire pour les lanciers et régine
donc à vous lui file un coup de boule à
au dj et je les ai empêché j'étais entre
les deux
je crois que j'ai fait croire que
c'était un sketch et enfin bon en tout
cas c'est anecdotique parce qu'elle se
bat là rapporter beaucoup d'argent pour
pour les équipements et voilà quoi ça ne
peut être qu'un bon souvenir ya pas d
une conscience sociale maintenant est ce
que est ce que vous êtes une nouvelle
votre partenaire michèle laroque
michel we en se vengeant régulièrement
elle est revenue de los angeles et ainsi
elle fait des allers venues supporter
l'été
[Rires]
quel bonheur ce spectacle avec michèle
laroque non écoute écoute les gens m'ont
parlé c'est vrai qu'on fait un couple
très crédible on n'a pas d'idées pour
continuer pour l'instant un troisième
écoutons un sens le nom et puis on veut
pas non plus en faire une recette quoi
donc écouter pierre on a tellement aimé
ce spectacle qu'on a décidé que vous
serez le premier entré dans le panthéon
2 tout le monde en parle
non ouais
gaillot
[Applaudissements]
l'intronisation de clients talma
d'industrie pierre toi et ton cortège de
bons jeux de mots nombre de sketches
magnifique voilà il mérite mais pourquoi
n'y a pas de kouchner il est vieux condé
sur bernard ne pas être entré au
panthéon petitclerc regarde la tronche
et non mais le docteur kouchner il s'en
fiche il a le prix nobel de la paix oui
enfin ça une photo ici quand même oui en
même temps le prix nobel de la paix oui
d'accord pour faire savoir roche pas
vrai moi je préfère avoir mes photos ici
la pression ça fait d'être le premier à
entrer au hall of fame de tout le monde
en parle
bon on sent aimé par ardisson et c'est
pas et y en a pas beaucoup qui peuvent
ils dire ça est ce que le lobby qu est
ce que le public a des questions à poser
à à pierre palmade enregistré au
panthéon
ils s'en foutent complètement est-ce que
vous avez qui suis-je
j'avais pas de questions à poser à
pierre palmade ici non plus tirer rien
prévient frédéric beigbeder à une
question frédéric ici non plus
si c'est pour le numéro de portable il a
déjà donné un
est-ce que tu m'aies michel à tes côtés
au panthéon
mettez la place tous les deux
oui c'est vrai c'est pas venue de toi
spontanément michèle laroque devrait
normalement être aux côtés de tout le
monde en parle il fait foi la rentrée à
part entré au panthéon tout le monde en
parlait et vous déguiser en clown de
france soir j'écris un album pour rose
laurens a memoir jeu
qui m'a demandé d'écrire un album de
chansons pour elle et voilà et puis
écrire des chansons il ya dans les
sketches on peut pas être tout on peut
pas dire des choses belles on oubliait
vers des choses drôles et les chansons
voilà ça me permet de dire du romantisme
ce que vous avez en vous voilà une
chanson hold up le taux de ce lot et
puis j'ai fini ma de répondre à thierry
je reviendrai fille je vais tourner et
marie-anne chazel comme acteur vous
faites plus que l'acteur maintenant je
vais pas chez l'acteur et puis je vais
écrire à muret à leur bain sur un
nouveau spectacle bien alors on dit
souvent des nausées sur les plateaux de
télévision et des fois même dans cette
émission
alors je vous faire pierre palmade une
interview avec des bips
[Musique]
alors qu'hier c'est vrai que vous aimez
beaucoup faire après le spectacle
j'aimais au début et puis ses fils à jo
dans j'étais obligé pied en amour vous
êtes plutôt ou plutôt à me la posent
toujours celle là
bah bip forcément ça vous a aidé dans la
vie d'être pour réussir à alors j'hésite
entre beau c'est beau ça peut être drôle
ça m'a beaucoup pays vous connaissez
bien michèle laroque on vous a dit
qu'ici même sur ce plateau l'année
dernière elle et moi on a vous êtes au
courant oui vous l'avez vu à la télé oui
c'est sur cible et avec véro vous avez
oui mais malgré ce qu'on pense oui
et cette histoire avec on en parle on
peut en parler ou pas tertio n'importe
quoi ah bon c'est n'importe quoi
si je vous dis vous pensé à créer un
bordel en régie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que tu peux y aller maintenant
parce que ça peut pas être mieux gens
qui devraient rentrer chez toi à pierre
là c'est un hommage énorme énorme depuis
maurice chevalier
j'avais vu ça franchement telle émission
sur moi dans une émission sur pierre
palmade ce soir c'est une spéciale passé
trois heures avec pierre ce soir de
pierre ou d'ailleurs
ça va durer tellement longtemps et je
vais en tout cas avancer mon siège parce
qu'il n'est pas il n'est pas au mieux
social j'ai vraiment besoin d'être
confortable nous allons passer de trois
heures tous les deux ce exceptionnel
mesdames messieurs on va commencer donc
à la naissance je pense qu'il faut
prendre les choses et là on l'a bien
pour trois heures c'est quel souvenir
pierre de ma naissance
oui j'ai très peur ça va empirer
ça va bien ça va dire vers la chine
espère au super quand je vois le plan
média bien non même si la locale genre
après
bon le loup le loup qu'on a vu vous
buvez rien pierre sobre ce soir qu'en
fait le sol un peu d'eau quand même même
pas même pas d'eau assez courageuse et
bien bien alors on a vu le look on a vu
la boisson la clean ça va il fait pas
trop froid
ça va bien
m
ça va dépendre des invités alors une des
raisons pour lesquelles je vous ai
invité ce soir pierre palmade
c'est un spectacle qui s'appelle il joue
palmade au point virgule à 19 heures du
mercredi au samedi alors ces deux jeunes
comédiens de 23 et 21 ans qui s'appelle
cédric sizaire et brice hillairet qui
reprennent une dizaine de vos sketches
mise en scène par vous voilà c'est un
hommage exceptionnel qu'ils vont rendre
on peut le dire mais ça peut faire un
peu prétentieux il joue pas le masque sa
peluche pour guitry non plus mais c'est
sais c'est un peu tôt peut-être qu'on
joue et je crois que j'étais pas très
très bons comédiens j'étais drôle
j'écrivais mieux que je jouais quand
j'ai commencé je crois hélas je crois du
coup mes textes et il les joue bien
effectivement on découvre que c'est très
bien écrit
ah oui moi je suis épatée par l'écriture
en tous les cas ils sont obligés de s'y
mettre à deux pour faire un truc comme
objet tout ça il me paraît bien et vous
avez obligé à se coiffer comme vous ou
non j'ai pas compris la question il fait
froid dont il aurait pu attendre que
vous soyez mort pour jouer vos sketches
quand même non
[Applaudissements]
ok quel effet ça fait guère c'est
bizarre quand maintenant peuvent pas
tant que ça je les regarde jouer baskuy
il sent son union parce qu'il respecte
les indications toujours et donner en
même temps il propose des choses elle
qu'est-ce-qui tournoi comme qualités
pour bien jouer palmade mettrait je suis
pas être très élégant mais les gants
non mais c'est bien peu faut pas vous
faire rire avec soin mais pas de soi
c'est pas la peine de sortir tous les
soirs de l'un d'eux non je pose la main
on risque de gelée de nom de la tribu
sexuels n'ont pas la même et c'est
important de le dire ça c'est pas
commencé la nuit entière non j'ai fait
une soirée chez moi et je te jure je
veux j'étais tellement bourré échouer la
soirée chiante jeudi être onu cette
soirée je me cache chez moi et j'ai
appelé un taxi pour rentrer chez moi
[Applaudissements]
le clac si l'on peut dire j'avais je
vais bien et cluzet qu'un et est le taxi
arrive je descends je monte comme je
peux dans le taxi et je lui donne
l'adresse et il me reconnaît il mais on
y est là là là je rencontre disent que
je faisais l'orgueil reprend le dessus
et je fais mais je sais je dois faire
des blagues
un voyeur ouais ouais bien y'a quelqu'un
qu'on voit pas trop la nuit en ce moment
c'est muriel robin elle est en tournée
non j'imagine au secours elle a fini
avec brio le 1 le grand rex et lanton et
là je crois qu'elle se repose mais elle
va bientôt partir en tournée comment ça
va avec elle très bien très bien vous
souvenez quand on avait fait le truc de
mayans poiret la c1 et plus beau cadeau
qu'on avait fait en télé c'est
c'est humain perd 8 de faire en sorte
qu'on se rappelle et qu'on n'oublie pas
maillant et poiret et slash c'est
vraiment très content ouais il ya
quelqu'un d'autre qui est sur scène mis
en scène par vous aussi décidément vous
n'arrêtez pas ça me plaît bien mais non
c'est vrai c'est jean jacques devaux
mise ancien et nouveau voilà on s'est
rencontrés sur les bancs de la classe
l'émission la classe
et voilà il m'a demandé ce que furent
mises en scène c'est à souhaiter qu'il a
écrit il ya 21h15 alors vous vous
reviendrez sur scène en septembre 2006
alors oui qu'est venu me voir il m'a dit
tu veux juin prochain une pièce je les
lui ai est formidable c'est avec
isabelle mergault 1
c'est génial de la chirurgie esthétique
c'est parfait et s'appelle si c'était à
refaire et ses frères fois que je joue
le texte de quelqu'un d'autre
je suis excité comme une puce est pas
mal mais sa variété
à la rentrée c'est quoi votre rêve
pierre aujourd'hui je reviens jouer avec
un week end hommes parce que j'ai pas
j'ai beaucoup joué avec blanche est un
formidable j'ai beaucoup travaillé car
sam j'aurais bien j'ai joué avec
quelqu'un qui ferait mon père avec un
brasseur ou ou un grand frère avec
bigard d'ailleurs sans peu en projet
travail et big c s'avance pas trop avec
des gamins pas prêt encore mais on se
cherche
vous allez cauchemar pierre bah oui ça
vous arrive souvent
oui oui oui ça va vous arriver ce soir
merde à faire une interview cauchemar
[Musique]
pierre vous ressembler à quoi dans vos
cauchemars je suis à l'école et le prof
me dit c'est parce que vous êtes célèbre
qu'il faut pas faire votre voix et je me
réveille ensuite sans savoir faire
évidemment c'est qui votre femme dans
vos cauchemars
ma mère à l'eau froide présents la
république dans vos cauchemars ceux qui
comme moi oui franchement je serais pas
quoi vous de la france vous acceptez
quel film dans vos cauchemars en faire
un film de cul parce que je
voilà on vous fait quoi comme critique
dans vos cauchemars
ok maintenant c'est que je mets en haut
mais le chemin vous vivez au caire dans
votre cauchemar ou dans des endroits
d'un cauchemar une île déserte où un
petit village
enfin là où il n'y a pas beaucoup de
monde n'est pas de bar la nuit et tout
ça m'arrête je fais pas que ça vous
écoutez quoi comme musique dans les
cauchemars à du rap
ah ouais mais pas seulement
enfin du rap et de la house va seulement
dans mes cauchemars dans les banlieues
où je veux aussi quoi vous avez peur de
quoi dans vos cauchemars pierre g j'ai
peur qu'on me pardonne pas et mes
erreurs
ouais vous mourrez commandant vocaux sma
un jour j'ai rêvé que je mourrais
comment elle a des noms de noyer dit
soutenir une voiture et je le loyer mais
revêt la voiture était dans un lac un
estomac est en train de conduire et on
découvre quoi sur vous dans vos
cauchemars je suis un mauvais coup vous
faites attaquer parquet l'animal dans
vos cauchemars
or je suis athée qui un jour par une oie
non mais c'est terrible vous faites
chargé par une oie s'est passé c'est
mauvais je sais j'en ai la campagne non
mais c'est vrai en même temps les oies
c'est un avantage c'est que c'est le
meilleur chien de garde loi oui et puis
on peut la bouffe et après chine au
grand palais nous fêterons le penser que
cette interview n'est qu'un cauchemar
qui va bientôt s'arrêter pierre tuvéri
un set à rien
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va et isabelle fer indiens
accusés vrai n'avait pas que deux mois
aussi grand
ça va ouais ouais connaître chaque coup
de sac
koné pierrot trop cool pierrot que les
arthur mois salir tiers final et laurent
c'est bon on va faire tout va bien et
les gens derrière
non non non alors isabelle et pierre
vous êtes là pour la nouvelle pièce de
laurent ruquier qui s'appelle si c'était
à refaire
alors justement si c'était à refaire
est-ce que vous retravailler avec
ruquier je suis déjà d'abord le fait et
puis oui ça que ça c'est un super cadeau
qui m'a fait un moment où je voulais
faire une pièce où je savais pas trop
quoi faire sur ce elle parle en effet
faire du one-man-show pas envie de faire
un duo parce que trop bon souvenir avec
michèle à eybens j'ai reçu le cadeau par
la poste de laurent ruquier une pièce
toute écrite moitié pas répondu à aucune
question pour moi à la base
non non je peux te la pause et aussi si
tu veux ah ouais si c'était à refaire
la question c'est si c'était à refaire
est-ce que tu travaillerait avec laurent
ruquier
ouais c'est là qu'à la base c'est une
pièce que laurent a écrit pour isabelle
main et après il a casté autour et c'est
isabelle qui m'a proposé c'est des fous
ce chiffre des fous chiffre supérieur tu
connais les slips hier au nom voilà
bonjour au majin à jack
j'ai toujours besoin d'enlever les
transports c'est qui c'est qui mais mon
dieu qu'est ce c'est bonjour oui évasion
réussie
non c'est yvan attal qui vient de
rentrer salive en live ans il vient de
rentrer d'amérique j'imagine bah oui et
nous l'interview c'est fini non pas du
tout mais alors jacques alie maintenant
jean d'ormesson a toutefois commencé et
pierre lancée au théâtre des variétés à
partir du 23 septembre avec le 23
septembre sera un peu emmerdé parce que
c'est là c'est la première du spectacle
d'arthur c'est la première au théâtre
des variétés de si c'était à refaire
mais lyon va jouer plusieurs fois à lui
non
[Applaudissements]
mais moi c'est ans je suis en provence
donc les connaître se détestent dans
marianne chaud souhaite bienvenue
sincèrement aux étudiants quand j'y suis
je dit oh là là mais qu'est-ce qui vient
marcher sur nos plates bandes marie tu
vois mais quand j'ai appris dans les
interviews qu'il y mettait 70 dans les
mains d'isabelle nanty j'ai dit ok sion
va revenir un peu à nous oui voilà donc
un spectacle bientôt c'est au mois de
novembre manche c'est au théâtre des
variétés à partir du 23 septembre donc
avec claire nadeau laurence badie noémie
de lattre alexia la manière et dans une
mise en scène de jean luc moreau
voilà voilà pas mal non ça fait une ça
fait une belle famille c'est un peu trop
beaux trop tôt pour le dire mais fait
une bonne équipe mais en tout cas on
travaille beaucoup avec jean louis son
travail mais c'est intense
on en avait un jour le connais pas
encore tous le texte mais on saura
combien de temps tu es tu chausses le
pitch ah oui faisait si bien alors le
pitch
donc je vais le faire un jeune coach de
nancy c'est le délire je le fais quoi si
les tarifs des pitchouns ou à l'api je
le fais moi beenie man pierre donc qui
s'appelle le docteur jouvence dans la
pièce dirigé une clinique de chirurgie
esthétique qui marche bien
voilà lorsque arrive une nouvelle
secrétaire qui jouait à bordeaux
voilà et dont votre femme claire nadeau
et est aussitôt très jalouse quoi ça
fait beaucoup
alors moi j'arrive vous avez winne le
pitre ou pas oui bon je prends le relais
donc nous sommes aussi imaginer la chose
nous sommes dans une crise sur l'afrique
esthétique donc pour ce faire ravaler la
façade lui est le nôtre qui retient moi
je suis la petite secrétaire je tombe
amoureuse de lui et là je n'ai de cesse
d'être jalouse des autres clientes qui
arrive n'est ce pas est délicat surtout
j'y suis je continue en fin de saison un
numéro extrêmement bien au delà c'est à
dire qu'elle dit elle pense tout quoi ce
qu'il faut pas faire dans ce milieu
donc c'est une espèce de madame sans
gêne voilà qui dit tout haut ce qu'elle
pense comme isabelle dans la vie dans la
vie la belle ne pense pas donc on
n'entend pas vous
non ça c'est pas drôle voilà merci
non mais c'est quoi la donc l arrêt dans
ce milieu là où il ya des patients qui
veulent que je suis censée tomber
amoureuse de monde
ces six ans est tombé amoureux de mon
chirurgien bon donc ça vraiment on est
dans la fiction mais bon les chipmunks
comédienne qui arrive
ouais hôpitaux on travaille et je ne
suis pas l'amoureuse de lui et puis
qu'est-ce qui se passe
enfin bon voilà on ne peut pas dévoiler
la fin ah bon non parce qu'on ne l'a pas
lu en même temps
alors isabelle vous avez déjà joué vous
dans une pièce de laurent ruquier presse
est unanime gros succès oui français
vous êtes tenté par la clinique du
docteur jouvence vous ne jouez pas bien
évidemment actionner besoin tout le
monde en a besoin cambier
mais il ya deux choses soit on a envie
d'être donne objectivement soit on
vieillit bien pour la personne qui vous
aiment qui est à côté de vous moi
personnellement que les personnes n'a
pas d'ennemi jackson on dira oui ne fait
pas partie de ma vie au bob il s'entend
de mai mais c'est vrai que tout le monde
dit assez solide vieillir oui c'est
solide vieillir quand on est en couple
oui on voit son conjoint vieillir avoir
des rides et tous ces jolis mais dans
l'absolu non c'est si vous êtes une
famille épargné par les rites quand même
non pas du tout moi elle je suis j'ai
vieilli comme tout le monde
prenons tout rose moi non si si toews
vous savez pas ce que c'est que la
clause c'est quand ça tombe
voilà pourquoi je mets mon cas mais ici
ça
zabel je suis d'accord avec jack lang
j'étais l'audio dans la petite sauterie
organisée par laurent ruquier je vous ai
trouvé un corps formidable avec des
bosses un un beau cul non mais vraiment
ça boulot et l'arrêt c'est bien je fais
10 km par jour
ras-le-bol je préfère à faire des mots
fléchés bon c'est sûr franchement
j'adore ça les mots fléchés
je suis obligé de faire de la gym et
tout ne s'est pas bien vieillir et moi
tous les gens qui disent c'est trop bien
les rides et ses annonces et si peu non
non c'est triste de vie dans votre
secret de beauté c'est vireur de sommeil
par jour de l'eau oui c'est ça comme
toute théorie comme huawei cwy est juste
je me nourris bien non mon secret de
beauté c'est que je me maquille à mort
et que et qu'elle fait bien aujourd'hui
que je suis un petit peu présentables et
faut pas que je fasse une émission
demain parce que je peux pas faire ça
tous les soirs c'est du boulot quoi
surtout surtout à partir après 22 ans
c'est terrible non non c'est les secrets
de beauté ça n'existe pas c'est moi je
dessine en rage non devrais je suis en
rage quand je vois des gens connus qui
disent oh bah moi il suffit que je dorme
bien que les une crème hydratante et
c'est alors que on sait très bien que
voilà et donc nous quand on entend ces
filles là on se dit mais [ __ ] mais son
élu de dieu quoi est le dieu dieu à
poser leurs mains sur rennes et l a dit
et il a dit que si tu as hommes et une
femme du nom oui mais c'est un homme et
il a dit toi tu seras pas comme les
autres et donc nous on est là qui ont
fait du sport mais les très maigre
hydratante et on n'est pas comme elle
voyez j'ai tant que c'est très dangereux
ces filles qui disent que il suffit d'un
rien alors que sont félicités à mort
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors pierre pierre bloch maire a
fait un lifting est allé chez le docteur
jouvencelles aussi à ça plus
sérieusement brûlée elle a fait ça il ya
pas longtemps du sahara concours de
circonstances un bal en parle à tout le
monde pour en parler avait elle dit dans
la rue bonjour j'ai fait un lifting et
elle a vraiment gagné 15 ans est
impressionnant maintenant comme ces
voilà donc si c'était à refaire de
laurent ruquier
mise en scène de jean luc moreau le 23
septembre théâtre des variétés
pierre vous vous pensez quoi pierre du
défaut de prononciation de d'isabelle
mergault ça que ça devient très très
vite un détail quand on joue avec elle
enfin si je dis ça devient la fois très
vite à détails parce que c'est vraiment
comédienne très très solide
ouais ouais et isabelle vous pensez quoi
du défaut de coiffure de pierre merde
non mais là ce soit on est vachement
millions parce que son coiffeur la colle
à la coupée mais sinon il a une coiffure
un petit peu ça fait un peu casque
culture là on est on est entre nous je
voulais te mettais mon record non non il
est il est un peu casque moi jamais pas
trop quoi
non non mais mais dans la pièce il est
traître il a un rôle très séduisant et
on est toutes séduite par lui qu'est ce
qu'elle a de plus sexy pour vos pierres
soumaré vous attendez deux grandes
pourquoi jack
cb
alors on peut tout dire à l'est berceau
quoi pourquoi tu ris et arthur qui peut
le dire oui et arthur j'ai rien fait
madame chirac étaient assis avec les
mains comme ça comme un océan de la
république lui a fait attention c'est
mitterrand allait super bien voler c'est
pour ça que laurent l'a pris parce que
c'est celle qui normalement est supposé
ne rien avoir à refaire super bien voilà
qu'est ce qu'il a de plus séduisant
il a un truc très séduisant c'est que il
croit pas qu'il est séduisant et ça moi
j'adore pierre qu'est ce qui vous énerve
le plus chez elle rien rien bien traités
générale est appelée revient elle a
intimement convaincu qu'il faut pas trop
qu'elle se montre elle veut pas faire de
télé elle veut pas alors bon alors
qu'elle fait tout pour nous aguicher
elle et moi et pas à la télé ce guichet
fermé voilà at il souffert mais j'ai
rejoué
ouais
aussi cet été oui trop vous n'êtes pas
eu le temps de lire la presse
non je n'ai pas trop vieille pas eu
vraiment le temps mais c'est bien on va
faire une interview people quiz
c'est la rentrée une forêt temps de
faire un point pi paul pillar isabelle
qui a les mains au dessus du buzzer avec
qui couchent claire chazal à l'heure
même où je vous parle là maintenant à la
santé alain santé claire chazal vite
avec comment s'appelle la mère des
enfants de patrick bruel
madame
6 kg gurria tout
[Applaudissements]
comment ça commence pas à oui mais c'est
tout ce que je sais bah oui à mon amende
à amanda sthers
bravo rires qui vient de rentrer en cure
de désintoxication mois
[Applaudissements]
attention on est prêt avec qui s'est
marié jean louis borloo cet été béatrice
schönberg quel autre mariage a récemment
été célébré mimie mathy comment
s'appelle le gendre de johnny hallyday
sympa jacques non mais on peut le dire
monsieur beigbeder
oui assez sa passe est officielle à
vendre est vrai que j'ai pas eu
l'adresse je veux bien que tu vas pas lu
la presse cet été en tous les cas avec
qui j'ai rarement accoucher cet été je
sais il ma mère alors ça c'est très
sérieux là c'est vraiment le people quiz
cécilia sarkozy est elle revenue je
demande le 50/50 jean-pierre regarder la
nouvelle non je crois pas la thalie
pernaut est elle revenue avec matthieu
ricard
oui
[Applaudissements]
qui a récemment déclaré qui a récemment
déclaré je n'ai jamais lu un livre de ma
vie je n'ai pas c'est baba aux
smartphones tiens j'ai pas assez de
temps pour lire des livres à 6 me non
non non non non victor hugo on me dit
mais grâce à beckham victoria beckham
exactement avec qui jean michel jarre at
il trompé sa femme c'est tout
non ils assez sa famille l'a pas trompé
avec personne part qu' antoine de caunes
at il remplacé elsa zylberstein
non
jeanne moreau pour les jeux on voit que
ça fait longtemps que tu as pas besoin
[Applaudissements]
daphné roulier les jolies daphné est
très jolie oui quelle actrice française
n'a pas eu d'enfant cette année carole
bouquet qu'après me donna catherine
deneuve
[Applaudissements]
ah là c'est très difficile qui s'est
fait bien baisés cet été merci je lai
sursis non c'est un garçon regarde son
bain c'est un garçon c'est pas moi c'est
vous charger le même nom un indice
d'abord chez vous un indice ça c'est un
indice à cette douleur a trop peur c'est
raymond domenech comment se doit les
palois et vous des deux maisons
[Applaudissements]
ok
est-ce que ça va plus je pense que ça
n'est plus qu'une pause glissement des
emprunts d'état
econocom commencé mais j'aime puis je le
connais jacques il est comme nous
simplement est obligé de frapper le
sérieux c'est normal il va être
président mais quand il sera président
n'ira bouffer chez lui comment se
prénomme comment se prénomme le futur
mari de paris s'il tonne
nos gars non paris sg-bordeaux baril
à 2 quel couple at-on annoncé la fosse
séparation cet été les temps atteint
faux et c'est faux si fous de ce qui est
faux de chez fo avec qui sort ophélie
winter en ce moment sa mère on sait pas
qui sort depuis cet été avec une coupe
pierre blonde trouvait dans un casino de
la côte d'azur
j'ai le jour qui sort depuis cet été
avec une croupière blonde trouvait dans
un casino de la côte d'azur
un type qui a envie de baiser
visiblement n'a répondu depuis laurent
gerra a mis les pieds à vie que non mais
non il est possible d'allumer ce qui est
horrible c'est horrible à ça va vite
alors que jack est toujours avec monique
c'est quand même alors quel drame a
frappé arielle dombasle cet été à la
piscine du ritz s'est cassé un os
j'ai un talon un lycée c'est pas le
vomir c'est pas loin
elle s'est fait interdire de rythme
parce qu'elle veut marcher en talons sur
le bord de la piste et on l'a obligé à
porter des espadrilles d'être unique et
des sandales décembre absolument
voilà je sors je m'intéresse c'est
important ça existe le monde extérieur
arthur non mais le coût de la non
patchées pas ils sont magnifiques le don
direct sur les dinos
voir si c'était envers le
en septembre dernier
ep
[Musique]